what's up kids this is a special episode
of firing the kids with mark norman
before we get into this juicy ass
podcast phoenix
next week we might be adding shows we're
almost sold out
phoenix stand up live november 5th
through the 7th that is next week
thursday friday
saturday with the boys here myself and a
special guest
and then november 19th through the 21st
we're in nashville
zaney's also a special guest with these
two boys as well
and then boise we almost sold out boise
december 5th
boise idaho it's actually right outside
but you get the idea
that thing is almost sold out a theater
out there in boise get your tickets at
tfk.com
phoenix you're on the clock see ya next
week come on chin
oh i gotta send you
i gotta send you in the picture you talk
about when i was on that thick horse
bruh
it cracked me up it hurt my feelings
though cause we're in montana
and we decided to go horseback riding
you guys scheduled the day before
and they asked for everyone's like size
and weight and my girl was like what
about 240.
why would she do that to you i was like
this she was about 250
give or take 10 pounds is this the price
is right so the lady was like
okay yeah we should have a horse farm so
we get there they pull out my son's
horse
tiny little thing pull up my girl's
normal horse and they're like where's
fridge at like who the [ __ ] fridge
dude the thickest horse you've ever seen
walks out the back
stopped i was like that's my horse like
that's fridge
i was like ah [ __ ] dude big
fridge hey did you get the pictures
i felt bad for this horse too yeah i
didn't want to go too long on them
and they're like yeah i think it's
pissed off right they're like i think
your
your weight's like effect like he needs
to pee so if you just like
let your legs go so he can peel it
because you're right on his kidneys
oh i let my legs are like this and just
this
[ __ ] pipe of a dick comes folding out
the side
that misses your hand [ __ ] dude
this big ashy dick comes out
and just super soakers the grout the
snow they don't put lotion on this
ding-a-ling
no because he's in montana it's snowing
it's cold
when he needs something he goes yeah it
goes in and out though
like oh like it's like does it like go
in yeah it's like this huge thing and
then
full oh is it like a sword in a sheath
like it just comes out and then you put
it back in
oh he's not just hanging out you're not
circumcised that ain't what he's saying
no because he got a helmet no no i don't
know it's weird-looking yeah i don't
know what he's talking about what are
you talking about like a turtle like how
turtle goes in and out of his head
i don't know what he does with that big
stick but it's not always hanging out
why are we talking about horses how old
was that horse
i think look at this thing i look like
look at him
look at him just living his best [ __ ]
life
i'm a ball says b look at that that
horse is like
damn yeah that's a thicky they call that
[ __ ] fridge they're called fred
jump hoes down
he said i'm ready for brendan's job
homie i came back got my
sick in my my hair was getting in my way
like no i was dope
i was like about it i don't feel like no
maybe i i said how long can somebody
ride this horse she goes
if it's a normal horse that does it
probably 10 hours like
really someone can be on a horse for 10
hours she goes if if the rider can take
it
she goes the horses can go damn there
all night but the riders usually
it's 10 hours and a break oh because my
[ __ ] were you chafing
uh just soaring because we got some time
10 hours dog
yeah like there's no way well think
about back in the day in the oregon
trail and [ __ ] they were on there that's
why i was asking
how long do people ride [ __ ] horses
for yeah she's like oh hours i'm like
this ain't for me
no did you live off your yellowstone
experience did you i did everything
think yellowstone if there was a [ __ ]
blizzard
it was so cold up there dog yeah because
when we booked it
i looked at the weather because my girl
goes let's go montana cause yellow
stomach all right let's do it
let's not go to the beach and be warm so
she wanted to go to
uh oh shout out shouts out
holla so look at her horse looking all
normal
i know right you got that
[Applause]
what's that horse do do but uh yeah so
she owned it when we got there it was
there's like a snow storm so it was like
negative seven during the day at night
got down to negative 14
so it's tough to do [ __ ] when it's that
cold man but that's probably used to it
they're used yeah that well kind that
that was the close they've had this
season
well that's like the cabin was dope it's
like my son oh look at his horse
yeah yeah his horse leah's tiny little
horse his horse name was whiskey
oh okay shout out to pete look at him go
was that your first time on a horse
uh yes it was damn are you serious yeah
i've never been over here
you guys been on horses i'm scared
well i love like i was all up on his
nose like i love horses noses but i'm
not like
i'm not like a big outdoors dude yeah
true you don't go camping and [ __ ]
when i was a kid i would but i hate the
cold so like it's intriguing for me dude
so my girl like i left denver i [ __ ]
hate the cold dude yeah so when you're
there my girl like
are you having fun that's one in the
snow i'm like i grew up in this so for
me it's like
i don't like this isn't fun for me yeah
like it's triggered for whatever reason
it's triggering for me
he loved it yeah but he loved it but
because it was dude
so say four degrees but then they would
tell you it's it's four degrees but it
really feels like negative seven
so tiger would be out there like we we
had a guy teach how to shoot bow and
arrow i saw that
and so we were out there for like 10
minutes then tiger was like hey dad my
hands are frozen
how about yeah we got to go
like it's just a cold that you can't
find but i bet i bet you know
because of that cold going inside to
that like wooden cabin oh
that had to like feel great my whole
thing was like starting the fire
fire it was dope i was the fire fighter
so you could do the fire starter and
then you
thought hell no no i'm from denver dodge
fire starter
i'm in big batches and i would get uh
like little twigs and you start with
little twigs yeah and then build up to
the big one
so i don't start like regular fire
that's a lot of hard work for no reason
it was fun though
i'd wake up at like 4 a.m okay i'll wake
up before i am throw that robe on
go outside they had to roll me outside
my size i mean the arms were short
whatever but uh
i don't think that's just i would make
coffee i'd go stare at the stars for a
hot second look at you because the big
sky
i'm telling you the stars are like right
here yeah oh [ __ ] and then i would get
all the firewood
start it before everybody got up it was
dope that [ __ ] felt like a movie a
little bit it was dope oh right
it was dope but you would love it jim
because he says it's like the fly fisher
out there he's like
if you're a fly fisher you know the
river we fly fish on because it's
literally
the place to fly fish it looks let's go
let's go he's like too cold
yeah he's like come back in the summer
there's certain fish that can handle
that
i mean they all handle it but it's just
you can't catch them because it's frozen
so for a lot of
thought it's frozen over or they're
super deep too so they go the deeper
they go the like
less cold it is for them i think it's uh
it gets colder yeah
learn how to shoot arrows and [ __ ] and
uh
i mentioned cam haynes yeah yeah i was
like ah they're like oh do not shoot
yours i'm like no some of my boys do
and i was even trying to name drum like
like i just say rogue i go my friend
joe's big in the hunting and then uh my
friend cam the guy's like cam
he's our teacher he goes can't like cam
haynes i go yeah that's him my boy cam
haynes i would
because i was wearing the campaign boots
oh because cam has
boots from under armour and i didn't
realize cam is literally like the kanye
west of hunting i had no clue really you
dropped his name they're like you know
cam haynes i'm like
yeah it's my boy like no i'm like yeah
i'll text him right now so i sent him a
video of a shoe i'm like look there he
is
and cam's like oh hell yeah cause i put
uh tiger turning little cam hanes
dude once they found out he's friends
with ken haines
um when i saw the name i thought it was
a country singer no dude he's he's like
uh
he's like the best he's like one of the
best bow hunters in the world
he's like an ultra marathon runner just
like oh really crazy marathon
outdoor stuff he got it like he
literally he's the guy
like when there's like bone arrow guys
he's the guy so he can survive in the
wild
yeah he's like he's like steph curry of
hunting what's that guy bear grylls
oh he just hunts he hunts but he also
does like crazy marathons he's
the guy though he got a moose on his
back i don't think he got a moose on his
back i'm just saying figuratively
like those would be yeah that'd be elk
that'd
but he's like like what do you cut the
head off that damn thing
cut the antlers off and then uh dressed
it in the field
can i elk damn dude oh we saw a moose
a straight up live shot of the rocky
ball shout out to moose rocky and bow
winkle dude you don't realize how big
mooses are to you getting to see him in
person
so i kept showing tiger videos and
mooses at night because showing the
wildlife there he's all into it
he was paparazzi mooses around here i go
there are but who knows where they're at
and then i told the dude the bone arrow
dude i go hey if there's a moose on
property on the ranch
ranch at rock creek i go if you if you
see a moose will you call and
let us know yeah next day at two o'clock
we're all chilling after eating
he goes hey we found a moose they're up
there up the stream
so they come pick us up we go and we're
like looking for the moose we can't find
it
finally this [ __ ] moose man by the
tree i'm like
god damn look how first of all they're
ten foot tall you know what
[ __ ] yeah for real yeah especially if
they're like with their their babies
of course yeah but i'm saying like by
the way they [ __ ] people up okay
people out there and they out there
killing them wait didn't that
uh you know that that nature show that
was on netflix
where they put these people out in the
wild playing by themselves
um alone alone yeah one of the dudes i
think he actually wanted he i think he
uh killed him killed a move how bone
arrow yeah i think bo
yeah you don't realize how big those
mooses are to get close to when you're
like
god damn yeah that's scary like we saw
like elk we saw like dare it's like all
right whatever
you see a moosh like holy [ __ ] it's
different
oh dude this they're so big yeah oh
that's the guy yeah whatever yeah yeah
bow and arrow that's a moose right yep
can you eat moose meat yeah yeah that's
he he survived
so what does moose taste like chicken
i've never had it i feel like it should
be gaming right
yeah but like i like gaming game it's
like uh
it's hard to describe it doesn't taste
as good as you would like
it actually tastes like almost like the
earth kind of in a weird way
like livery i would say if you you had
liver
sometimes the reason it's more gamey
like there's a lot more nutrients that
like an
elk like it's gamey like it's way better
for you than say like beef you get from
the store
oh like there's a ton of nutrients in
elk and elk people i mean elk is like
well because all they eat is grass and
[ __ ] yeah there's no
hormones in it there's no you know
steroids like it's all yeah
[ __ ] got it smoke elk and that's what
people eat is that big out here in l.a
that's not big not in l.a
unless you're [ __ ] friends with rogan
he gives you like elk sausage all the
time like i guess i'll take this dude
you ate elk before oh yeah is it from
rogan no it's delicious oh
but i want i had elk in montana too
damn those are some elky [ __ ]
it's good for you man
so would you ever like hunt you you're
not a big i would huh yeah i would hunt
you know my boys hunt and i'm usually
into the same [ __ ] as them so i'm like
yeah i'd be down for it
i got some friends in texas that want to
take me uh shooting them damn uh
warthogs yeah the javelinas or whatever
they want that mess up your farm because
it's you and it's year-round yeah
that they're able to do it because they
have a problem though yeah they have a
problem with it because i guess
the doors are destroyed like yeah like
and they made like a [ __ ] so
they produce a bunch of offspring
so it's like if they don't control it
they destroy
they destroy the land damn that's a
little but to me it'd be dope to go like
cam obviously he's the [ __ ]
kanye west of hunting but if you go with
cam keep saying and he kills that thing
and then you like dress it and then
[ __ ] eat it late at night
i heard they don't don't eat those
things elk no the oh the
them damn boars wild pigs no not because
i have more
than i think yeah they just leave them
i think it's tough meat some people eat
them but i i don't think so like tim
you have to like prepare tim kennedy
goes out of a [ __ ] helicopter and
shoots them down yes
i've seen videos of that yeah they did
on batman
they did that so you don't eat it you
don't eat it yeah they're just you're
just
merking them you never stop [ __ ] with
the land the pink ones i think
i think i could do that i think you know
i could kill i went boar hunting in
hawaii and the promise is they showed me
a baby one before we left and it was
cute as [ __ ]
i'm not killing that so i was in the
back and i'd make a lot of noise
and they would turn around like dude
quit making i'm like oh my bad
you're trying to save me yeah we got
done he goes you know this is the only
trip we've ever had
where we never shot a boar like really
that's crazy because i was super loud
what were you doing what were you doing
i just was like hey are we good
like no no no none do that i wanted to
save the board
they were so cute i couldn't should have
yeah shoot a little one how are you
going
in the video show me the little one
earlier and we were like two [ __ ] pit
bulls that would
hold them down then you gotta take a
knife and like cut their throats wait
what oh yeah because they do it
differently right in hawaii different
they have a dog
grabs the boar like one to take one side
and one takes the other then you come up
and [ __ ]
just like i love how like
that's zero animal cruelty is not the
one
i'll shoot it from a distance so i have
to deal with it yeah that's so crazy
well [ __ ] i don't know i i can't do it
how long is hunting like what two hours
a movie they they go for days
wait days it's like that's like that's
why cam hayne's in such good shape
he's gone for like six days doug to
catch one moose and they're burning like
three thousand calories a day hiking
walking carrying all that equipment
man it's a real beast doug that is some
[ __ ]
one time
for one i don't like ice outside i pay
rent all right
i'm not about to get no animals many
animals don't yeah where do they stay
yeah they sleep that set up tents thank
you
thank you and you think the mosquitoes
love your mouth malik why are you
dressed like you sell
fake yeezys why are you dressed like
this right now i mean delivering stuff
thank you brother i don't like that you
thought we're gonna dress up for
halloween i thought it was a halloween
episode
i got here our boy brian johnson made
the pumpkin yeah i thought it was in the
spirit then i saw y'all
yeah you got it i love it yeah i think
it's a dope outfit i'd wear it anyway
thank you
i'm i'm uh two-part from parties yeah
dude as soon as i got in your car i was
like tupac from look at that there it is
that's me oh you knew it right away yeah
i knew it right away i knew exactly not
me i was like oh that's a dope outfit
you thought i had to go where are you
going yeah he looks dope
i thought i'll wear that yeah yeah thank
you i appreciate it i got this
[ __ ] hipster mullet now talk about it
oh well what's up
we got beverly hills in the top west
hollywood and down the back yeah
what's up represent representatives
swing your head brenden
you really
i look like an actor from sons of
anarchy oh yeah shout out to sons of
anarchy
that was a good ass series what are you
guys doing for halloween oh we was just
talking about it watching a fight
uh the ufc fight or are you talking
about you talking about uh tank tank and
it's the same asian guy santa cruz
santa cruz oh yeah leo santa cruz and
tank are fighting on showtime
pay-per-view only
if you need a 30-day free membership
showtime.com
i'm sorry i love how you plug that in
plug it you've always been this much
you're always business no but they got
they got this asian dude i was telling
about that dawg who's the asian king i
don't know people said
they told me that you say his name
they played him they played his
highlights during the lomanchinko and uh
uh lopez fight and i'm like yo who was
this guy that was like chin cousin i was
like okay
he's the main event so taco somewhere
else yeah yeah yeah top-ranking
are you gonna watch tank and uh leo of
course who you got thanks to this guy
tank's your boy yeah i i like tank i
worry about his commitment issues i'm a
leo santa cruz fan
i think leo's more fundamentally sound
mayweather but he's just a little older
so i think
tank's a huge favorite so it's not like
i'm going to bet you or anything no
i'll do a friendly bet but my boys
what's the friendliness of 400.
if you want to bet those those are i
mean which ones did you just get which
ones did you do i got the original
uh off white jays uh jordan ones the
original the uh
the red and white yeah yeah when we put
the green laces in there yeah y'all need
to y'all need
that that's the sickest shoe oh my
christmas call me chris and it took me
three years to get them
i know shout out to three
i mean there's many kids around but
should there's gonna be food if you
wanna come over halloween party at the
christmas we got food you got
can i wear the same old uh wear that for
sure a lot of pizza what day is it
saturday saturday oh so i know saturday
two o'clock
saturday two o'clock i like that oh you
want to know you guys are invited to
early risers
okay well two o'clock because they're
four years old japan
[Laughter]
oh y'all do it earlier [ __ ] huh yeah i'm
a dad man
you know i'm a dad i felt where you
coming from we trick or treat late
i get it yeah bro what time should you
come over about nine yeah
okay come over at nine i'll be my
underwear upstairs you ain't still come
i got this lebron james goat shirt just
for malice
i'm in my underwear and i got my hat on
getting ready for my town went ready to
go for montana boys and sent it to this
he's just in his underwear i threw my
phone
i said this is for you mal you i did not
ask i didn't i didn't ask for this
i did not i saw this shirt but then it
was like i clicked all like how about
the hoodies i got us though
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you should be coming
this week yeah y'all got hoodies for me
he did the lakers thing don't worry
about what it's a laker thing shout out
to the dodgers are you representing
how about them dogs 17 years old
fireworks hard last night
fireworks even in uh woodland hills
[ __ ]
like a [ __ ] is that a flex i
guess it is west side
oh dump now yeah so the valley's poppin
you how was it by you how was it my girl
goes thank you for telling me because i
i i posted it on my instagram because i
don't see social media so my girl goes
man it looks crazy where chen's i go he
lives downtown downtown
probably the worst place to live holy
[ __ ] that's definitely for that stuff
um wait hold on i'll let you give me a
hundred dollars yep which i lost by the
way
let's see it chen i'll show you the
actual stuff though so it started off
like that
right not too crazy then it got like
that
where are they trying to go yeah what
are you doing they're just trying to go
inside
to where to the the city downtown i
don't know to destroy it but the dodgers
aren't even down
there i know you're doing it i just
don't live downtown it's for cobia
it's really they're hitting my window
with fireworks i told you
yeah oh dude i'm i'm done oh december
i'm done
you are you moving to december yeah i'm
moving to december where are you moving
to uh i have no idea here's your address
doug
oh i actually might talk to you about a
studio situation too but check this out
and then so people are burning out in
front of the cops
right in front of i saw this here it
gets
just for reference look here's here's
what you got to understand
is la i found this out right when i came
here
it's not a laker town it's not a rams
town
dodger i see way more dodgers winning is
a big is it
32 years it says 88 yeah it's up 32
years
it's a big [ __ ] yeah but you got to
understand the lakers came from
minnesota
right yep that's why they're called the
lakers we don't have lakes here exactly
i didn't know that they had absolutely
no korean
plate that's why they called the lakers
yeah but the dodgers came
from brooklyn from brooklyn to the draft
and that's roger it's weird how they
accept the dodgers more than the lakers
they've been around longer
the young boys have been here longer
though yeah yeah but i'm saying
i'm saying the fact that baseball look
the angels what about the angels
they joined about orange county that's
orange county well you know we don't
know
bro okay i'm sorry would you do a leader
they changed it though right angels
changed from like
orange county to that anaheim
you know what's weird is like the la
really doesn't accept the rams even
though they're they started off as the
la they got it they got a warning
they got to warm up then we really don't
we don't even care about the chargers i
don't even know why they're here
no not at all and their ticket sales are
[ __ ]
no football it's a sc ucla correct
correct
and when football is popping it's when
the colleges are popping they haven't
been good forever
so but it's it doesn't matter if you
have to go around la and ask what do you
care about more the dodgers lakers or
the rams
i bet overwhelmingly dodgers there was
so many interviews on ktla
uh just like yo interviewing you think
like they don't care about the lakers
out here but the dodgers won
they had gear we've already forgot about
the lakers if we forgot about talking
about it lebron had to
come back he's like hey man dodgers we
did it i was like
there was no parades or nothing for the
lakers waiting for the dodgers to come
back it's gonna be nuts
damn how about the my problem is the
narrative on the espana was homeboy who
got kovid
who's the life of the team you talk
about justin turner yeah they're justin
turner
they told him he had kobe in the eighth
inning and he was like
well we're about to win the world series
so they he still celebrated without a
mask and a mask on
but instead of the narrative being that
the dodgers finally won a world series
in 32 years
the narrative on [ __ ] woke left espn
was
covid he's gonna infect the other guys
they should put him on a bus took him
home it's like [ __ ] that's the captain
of the team
so here's the wild thing to me like okay
so cam newton had got it right
yeah the oral but no one else on the
team got it no couple people else
they other people got it other people
got it but cam had to take
off and they came back and he's way
worse yeah and
courtney yeah
[Music]
again everybody's different everybody's
different
cam got worse cam
[Applause]
yeah my cardio got better copy that
i see what you're saying uh but yeah
that's so weird during the dodge
celebration has just in turn returned
the field despite being told to isolate
after
testified for kobe 19 during the game
first of all why would they
oh what i guarantee you if they asked
the team that hey
you know justin just you know he tested
hot
for kovitz and we know we're going to
win the world series
he's the life of the team do you want me
to go on a bus back to hotel and miss
the world series finale
or do you care if he's here every single
one of those players i'm like oh dude
yeah we'll risk coving and he kissed his
old lady and he kissed this lady yep old
lady hell yeah
that's how you got to respect your queen
dawg at any time you're in the world
series
respect your queen dwight howard
respected his
queen he got disrespected well then he
got disrespected but still
but yeah that's that's so ridiculous if
i'm the captain and i catch covet i'm
not coming out there like
damn it they i celebrate from afar but
i'm not getting off the field
like bro you understand this is a 17
year old driver oh you're not getting me
out you're not getting me out i'm like
i'll stay over here
i'll wear a mask or whatever i'll ask
the guys but i i bet you most guys
like now we're healthy especially
because what was it a year or two ago
when they
made it to the world and got swept yep
yeah yeah
but but that's was he on the team at the
time yeah of course
yeah yeah y'all bro it was an asterisk
and yesterday they may celebrate they
used to watch i can't let them celebrate
yeah
that's the team see what they want you
know what they played the game until the
seventh inning
like eighth yeah like yeah it would have
been fine anyways
yeah you already contaminated the whole
damn game then
yeah you're going to shut down him shut
down the whole damn game shout out to
the temple base
manager he looks like snail was killing
us
snail the pitcher i know he was killed
that's why i said shout out to the
manager thank you kevin cash you doing
who's he working for that was about to
say he was like let's go ahead and pull
i was like oh tight move that's awesome
because we weren't winning we wasn't
doing anything
did you see brought in the other
pictures went off come on man
come on bro i was like thank god but how
about mookie betts won a world series
with the uh boston red sox and it came
like cool story i'm gonna make all this
money with la and win them a world
series yep
rivals hey shout out to rondo he did the
same thing
exactly he did now now here's the thing
i was watching a lot of sports center
this morning hold on i can't get this
where do you even get that outfit from
yeah that's the truth is that you're not
getting that at the store
not buying that who knows where you yeah
what poor
person do you jack their entire work
outfit from i didn't jack i didn't do
anything
i don't i don't want to say their names
for legal reasons now because you know
they can get faster
your legs is different what do you mean
they bigger right you and jon jones have
the same legs
damn bro is that i've never really like
full on because you're always in pants
and [ __ ] you're talking like you could
tell you got little legs
don't say that like these shoulders why
are your calves bigger than your thighs
yeah we're
like what the hell wait hold on tight
wait what are we doing you never notice
your legs dog well dog they still
want some of mine no don't
you look like you've been in a
wheelchair since you're 18.
i came here because i thought it was
halloween episode
and i went all in and i put lotion on my
legs your costume should have been
bigger legs
but decide just to start walking like
yeah you got lieutenant dead legs bro
you got legs so you said if i get up
right now i remind you lieutenant
that's what you say if i get up right
now everybody okay [ __ ] it
you got the most legit halloween outfit
i've seen well bro this is a real poster
uh
yeah that [ __ ] is good that top is fly
yeah
yeah i'm clean now yeah no it is a clean
outfit if dogs don't look down no why
are you keeping it okay
stop talking edit that out we edit that
out because
we keep that in yeah this is a [ __ ]
wow
like i said i was watching sportscenter
oh all right yeah as you were saying
what was uh
was uh fireworks going off by your house
of course of course it was
popping it was probably but not for long
no
not no yeah it went to 12 30 on where we
were oh really for hollywood
oh wow i was stopped like and were they
protesting down there no
what was it just was it downtown
downtown was the craziest for sure
they're breaking stuff looting
oh spray painting everything people just
want
reasons to [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah it's so
stupid like a stupid have a celebration
don't destroy everything
have you seen what's happening philly
well shout out to uh walter
shout out to suplex shoe store hopefully
he didn't get robbed shout out to them
boys
hello yeah i've seen that yeah philly
lose or something can i can i report
this room nope go ahead and report this
story
this is not my real estate that's why
he's wearing this poster he's delivering
my delivery i got two stories
shitty stories you don't know that yet
brennan
i was up all night good okay cool yeah
what's the story
check this morning glory so so so at in
philly
right this guy he got a call they got
the police came for like a
duress call you know how that is the
black guy had mental health issues but
he had a knife in his hand
right so they recording you know they're
like hey yo you know they yeah
yeah i mean yeah just come down just
calm down
the police are like yo we didn't have
any tasers he was there for domestic
violence domestic violence but he had a
knife in his hand now his mom like yo
she's shouting out like put the knife
down they're going
you know stop stop he's charging towards
the
car with a knife and they don't have any
tasers right
so boom of course the shots the shot the
cops
shoot him they shoot three times i think
it was a three or more i don't know
philadelphia shooting yeah i think it
was more than three was it yeah
but either way but you're charging a cop
with a knife what do you think's gonna
happen
why don't you go you're gonna get shot
you're getting shot exactly
but so now they're saying but hold on
hold on here's the thing he had mental
health issues
so does that make it okay to charge a
cop with a knife
well he was walking briskly towards him
can't have it you can't so you're saying
that that right
but but no hold on after and during this
climate now i don't want to get too deep
doing this okay so during this climate
right we've seen so many videos of a
black guy
getting arrested and getting i mean
getting killed right and we see like
other people
like you know other races get a you know
i saw a white woman
literally like had like with a knife and
she was hitting the cop and they don't
shoot her they don't shoot her yeah
right and these days that's the problem
they're tasering her so i'm saying
three times by the way three it was
three okay boom but where was it
they couldn't shoot him in a leg okay
copy that they don't yeah that's not
they're not trained to shoot yeah
they they're trying to stop they trying
to stop okay so
i'm saying my issue is and this is my
issue yeah i'm like i'm like i'm like
dog like why
why keep killing like we just had like
another protest now you already know
what's going to happen you know what the
city the city is going to go up and then
30 cops is injured and then a lot of
people are getting it's like 97
[ __ ] up so it's the top but here's the
problem the thing too
is like protesting i'm all for it man
use your voice you use your power
the problem is is it turns from protest
it's not everybody
but then it's the looting so now they're
destroying the city yeah
destroying philadelphia but we got to
pay for that taxpayer still got to pick
my point
so you're not hurting those cops you're
hurting your
your your neighbor you're hurting those
black owners of those businesses whose
livelihood is in those business like my
boy's own suplex look
historical shoe store dude they're
self-made
that's the business they put all their
might to you you rob
them it's like they don't have the money
and the way insurance works it doesn't
cover it
it doesn't cover that what if you file
for bankruptcy you just you literally
can get the insurance claims we
some but like like those big businesses
like nordstrom's stuff and foot locker
yeah
they can get away with it yeah but those
mom and pop shops are those
shops they're [ __ ] dudes their entire
savings are in that
so when you guys loot and [ __ ] you you
guys meaning this community
true i forgot about that i was so into
you know what the losers aren't
but losers are what i mean you guys it's
losers white black and fifa
proud whoever it is yeah you guys is
these looters like
that's not protest logan paul's brother
yes
for real but when you loot it you're
what you're doing is now
you're putting a check whether you're
pro-trump or not you're putting a check
into his box
exactly because then people want law and
order and they want the national guard
and the national guard gets in philly
today exactly and you want to see what
happens in the national guard
oh it's going to be a curfew and they
don't respect that oh it's all going to
stop it's
not going to get away with it but that's
that's the thing it's just the same
cycle that we go
it's the same cycle like i always think
about like
you know i don't know reacting the same
way to the same situation
like are you getting the results you
want are you getting the results you
want because that's crazy
that's what crazy is doing something
over repealing over without any positive
it's like it's like like i think about
that like with my anger like i was
reacting the same way you're having
problems like
after the name nothing got better so i
had to like
open my mind and change up and like okay
how can i strategically
go well i mean my teachers helped me
with that yeah how can i react different
what what can i do
to get a better result to get a better
result well look at like but also when
they
loot and destroy the city like look at
watts they destroyed those businesses
is watts flourishing as are those
communities flourishing
when you burn down as those building
cities like that dude
you're talking about years before they
rebuild and come back
business and then also businesses don't
want to come back there
because they go oh it can happen here
we're going to take our business
elsewhere
so they're scared to bring money into
that community so it [ __ ] those
communities for
you're talking generational dude you
ever seen that famous video
uh i think it's from the uh l.a riots uh
rodney king getting bit up yeah it was
it was a black dude that was uh
he had a business and he was an older
black dude and he was like
it was it was it's kind of like hard to
watch because it makes you want to cry
is he defending him
yeah he was like man y'all destroyed
like because i worked hard and like
people were trying to like and they're
falling down but he was
it's like a heart it's a heartbreaking
video like watching i'll tell you who
you don't want a business you don't want
to [ __ ] with because
there's a lot of asian especially
chinese people that own business in
watts
you see what they did when they're
trying to riot they got on the roof
with ak-47s ar15s went if you come into
my store i'm gonna shoot you
no one [ __ ] with the stores so it
wasn't wats it was a it was los angeles
riots in the 90s
they're like korea owners by the real
quick the
so different articles are saying
different things it says
the the main thing common is that the
two officers i think was two officers
shot seven times each so there's like 14
shots but they're not sure how many
times he was struck
yet i thought he was hit three i thought
they visited him three times before
in the video you can hear like yeah
several shots i hate articles
articles bug the [ __ ] out of me really
well you don't know what you don't know
what's real
yeah it's just so much man everything's
just if you look at cnn it's gonna be
the worst case scenario you look at fox
and your best case scenario it's like
what's you just watch the video is the
video you watch the video yeah
it's multiple shots it's multiples more
than three but yeah i'll just say like
i'm with you it's like in this current
climate now
let's put let's say you two are the cops
and it's me and we don't know each other
and you come to a domestic violence call
and i'm outside with a knife i'll beat
you you're not going to beat my ass
no you're not going to beat my skin you
want to go home to your wife and kids
and i have a knife and i'm going to try
and stab you whether i'm mentally ill or
not i'm going to try and stab
you and you have a gun what are you
going to do well hold on this isn't to
me
don't get me wrong there's some bad cops
out there making horrible decisions and
we got to fix that that's a real problem
it's a real [ __ ] problem we got to
fix that but there's
millions of uh encounters with cops a
day that we don't see
between white and black or black on
black and it goes great but that's not
posted
no one cares about that for the most
part cops are doing their job
so those two cops they won't go home to
their wife and kids man
so if you're rushing me with a knife and
i'm trained to shoot to stop you
and it's me or you i'm [ __ ] it's not
a race thing
it's a fear thing no i hear what you're
saying but in that situation the point
the floyd
floyd the floyd thing's different 100
it's countless other but i'm saying in
that situation he wasn't rushing
he wasn't rushing it because he went
around so what should we do though mouth
if
i'm a cop and you're briskly walking
with a knife his mother let his mom
like they told his let his mom calm him
down like his mom was right there you
for you to get shot and like more than
like several shots
i don't know what the estimated i'm
hearing different things but multiple
shots multiple shots
and in front of his mind you know listen
the dude is already thrown off
right and plus black people suffer from
mental health issues we got to make that
bigger in the community
so the whites you know so the white guys
want to see him crazy exactly so
the fact that he was walking and his mom
was like yo i got him let me
you know let know how to deal with him
to calm him down below
no because listen so the cops was
walking around the car can we play that
video
oh no i don't know i'm sorry i don't
know i don't know i don't know we played
mr hands i don't know
i don't know i don't know where we draw
the line i don't know what we're drawing
but i'm just i'm just saying he was
walking around the car he was walking
around the car breath
and so the cops are are are walking
around the car so it's clear it's clear
distance
right and the guy is filming i don't
know about the guy is filming in the
back seat
right so he's seeing he's like yo just
chill yo he was like yo let his mo
his mom got you know he's shouting all
that was the mom coming to get him his
mom was grabbing his arm
and what was he doing he was still
walking towards the cops
so now you said in that situation what
should you do no they don't have i want
to go home to my kids i don't give a
[ __ ] if you're crazy if your mom's there
i want to see my kids
okay so you're coming at me with a knife
i'm going to shoot you look how far
distance
they just watched the video though okay
oh it's okay you can't show it if
someone gets shot and died you can't
show it
but you know what i'm saying like it's
to me this isn't this isn't a race thing
this is a matter of
a lot and a lot of those cops don't have
the proper training to deal with it so
you put those guys in their stress they
have a gun they see a guy with a knife
they're shooting so that's that's why
when people say defund the police like
if you do that if that's your motive and
you want to defend the police things are
going to get worse
because you're going to get cops who are
less they have less resources you can
get
worse cops you need to put more money
into them to get proper training
no i i get what you're saying 100 but i
think the people that's just like saying
defund the police
is we're watching a guy with a knife
charged two
two officers right but we watch someone
from different races
and they literally fight just to restart
that's the problem that's that's one
thing
i get both sides i get what you're
saying yeah right
both sides exactly yeah and then i get
like that i try to put myself in this
situation
you know because i had plenty of run-ins
with the cops and and
like you said always been negative not
always but
here's the thing the black cops treated
me worse than a woman oh man
because they they have something to
prove i'm like god damn they hit me up
i'm like yo
so it took like a white officer to calm
the black guy down weird
yeah i was like what the [ __ ] i was in
the car i heard the same thing but i
literally had the same thing black
officer going hard going hard and still
i was just trying to mess with my record
yeah
yeah he got so mad he could have let me
go to cop was like let him let me go but
he was like nah
i'm i'm just ticking i'm gonna give you
a
just like you said like the white cop
was like like chill dude yeah okay like
yeah like he was just
he just started talking [ __ ] about me
like i was just like
well i'm i'm trying to you know just
like uh
you know comply just i understand yeah
like listen i'm not i have no reason
to you know like any information you
need from me
yeah i will give you i'm i'm not here
i'm not against you yeah
i'm here to like cooperate with you you
stop me
obviously there's a situation let's
understand there's a real problem
between the relationship between
cops and black people too like yeah the
way a cop black or white approach is
he started talking [ __ ] about like bro
my my clothes he
started talking [ __ ] about like just me
right now he took my
man you you want money cops have a tough
job too man because they're dealing with
the worst of society
every day they don't have a positive
outlook yeah and i get that but i wasn't
even
saying anything [ __ ] i wasn't saying no
he took my chain
i was like yes sir he's like
[ __ ] you two nights well yes
sir i am too nice
i told you yeah yeah there's some
[ __ ] out there but
i mean there was one cop she thought she
thought i was uh
robbing the atm and i was depositing
cash but she's like yeah i'm like
how could i you know and the thing was
that then that like suck
don't get me wrong i've dealt with some
really great cops there was one cop that
stopped me because i was about to go
fight some
dudes with my brother yeah and they had
pulled us over and caught us or whatever
and um oh that was that was the house
yeah and then yeah and then my brother
had the nerve to be like
uh my brother's trying to fight these
dudes and i was just rolling with him
yeah he straight up snitched on me
and they were like is your brother in
the car and he was like yeah he right
here wow
you gonna do me like yeah
i was just like hey you know what we're
going we're going back
to our neighborhood we don't want to
fight these guys we understand that they
don't want to fight
i was just talking to them being honest
with them and even one was like oh you
uh i had a band t-shirt on he was like
started talking about it
yeah he was like oh you listen to gbh
and i was like oh yeah you know one of
my favorites
and then you know they're like he was
like hey man like if you're not gonna
he goes i'm gonna trust your word if you
if you guys are gonna go home
and you gotta think yeah there was three
black dudes two mexicans in the car
at the time you know like coming from
coming from like the suburbs a white
neighborhood like gilbert arizona which
is you know
um you know we were headed back to mesa
shout out to mesa
but uh you know he was he was actually
really really cool but like
yeah have had those situations if we're
like they are cool and they just they
like i always try to you know my best
just to
you know it's it's tough comply proper
yeah but even when you comply
they they still go hard so it's just
sometimes i tell you that i'm saying
i'm just saying my run is like like you
know i'm close with a few cops i was
talking this cop the other day
this is what he would be close with a
few cops
this stink boy but this was his monday
this was his monday i go how was your
day he's like [ __ ] man he had
he had like all these scratches on his
head and was all [ __ ] up
and he goes uh this lady uh car broke
down
it was like an older navigator whatever
uh broke down
and so we're trying to help her out
because she's had a dangerous part of
the highway he's like so i pull up
and she's or right off the bat mexican
ladies just being a dick
and he's like listen we're just trying
to make sure you're safe we're gonna try
to restart the car
wait for the tow service to restart the
car and they're trying to restart and
shoot she won't get out of the car
he's like all right whatever he's like
it's not safe here you're in a dangerous
part of the highway and she's just
talking [ __ ] to him he's like all right
whatever
and people always you know especially
now people are [ __ ] to cops even if
they're good cops they're [ __ ] to
them
so they're trying to restart the cars
restart the engine but and they're
trying and it's a
smaller battery on this navigator and
the
tow truck guys like this battery
shouldn't even be in this thing i don't
know so i'll try my best so
he's like trying to get it he's hitting
it and she's like start talking [ __ ]
like don't touch my [ __ ] car like
that
blah blah blah and he's like dude we're
just trying to get the car straight be
cool
they're trying to start trying to start
this lady gets out of the car
jumps into the tow truck steals the tow
truck my buddy who's a cop
jumps in the tow truck is wrestling with
her
on the steering wheel and the keys gets
the keys out
right get finally gets the keys out she
starts attacking him he goes like
you know he's like this to go away she
brave she gets out
runs across the highway makes it past
the first light
this is rush hour makes past the first
lane
makes pass she's 20 something years old
makes past the
second lane makes past the third lane
gets
to the carpool cars going 80 miles an
hour
hits her game set match that was his
monday morning she died it's over she
died
come on i mean i knew that i knew 80.
when you say match
that's right dead on dead on site
that was his monday fellas
mental health issues maybe
i'm just saying but but that's his
monday this is monday and then but that
was monday morning what happened on
tuesday
i don't know he went he went back he
went back to work okay
but that's what he deals and he's like
you know you have no idea why she did we
don't know
we have no clue you have no idea why she
did it what she was thinking
she was on parole yeah oh she was yeah
so maybe she was thinking oh the the
cops here he's gonna run my um on parole
but it's like
he was like she didn't do anything wrong
she's gotta check in
yeah but she might she probably did
something before so she's on parole like
you know so
like she can oh is that pending pearl's
like you if you like
you got to check in and like if you do
anything you're going straight back to
jail
got it yeah but she didn't do anything
nothing she didn't do anything illegal
you know like they ran the place on the
car like oh it's like parole but it's
like
got it you know like she he was like it
doesn't make sense why she would run why
she'd steal the
the truck like none of it made any sense
we're there just to help her out to
start the car
yeah yeah he's like he's just a normal
you know
yeah i get it guys i mean and they're
just like [ __ ] dude
yeah it's just like we get it cops have
like a
tough job i get it you need proper
training because the elijah
what does that mean what does that mean
no proper training well if you like
jocko
uh willak who's on rogan you know who
trains
cops well he's a former special forces
guy
but he's saying you know a lot of these
cops have barely any training so they're
not getting because we need cops so bad
they're not properly trained we're
putting them out in the field
so you got a guy who's whatever 24 years
old not a lot of life experience
high pressure situation you give him a
gun and
he his odds of dying you know when they
pull a car over
high if it's you know a certain
ethnicity so he's scared already
that guy starts mouthing off he's
freaking out he don't know how to deal
with the situation
they're over aggressive yeah it's just
like he so you know
you need they need more training they
need proper yeah they need guys like
jocko or tim kenney to
help them with you know hannity tim
kennedy is a
special for current special forces guy
uh ufc
fighter used to be a ufc fighter well
literally
when you talk about if aliens came to
earth and they're like hey we need to
one of your greatest human beings tim
kennedy
he's the nicest guy great father current
special forces guy
damn oh he went from ufc to the special
forces he was in the
special force wall in the ufc oh really
he's a [ __ ] wow the nicest guy
on the planet
i mean huge dropped dang what is he
fighting at
brook middleweight parking ticket that's
a middleweight middleweight imagine
what's middleweight 185. 185. freak
damn that's the thing man special forces
too
hell yeah social forces wow you hear him
talk about trump and funding you're like
oh
like he makes funding it makes sense
it'll make you just be like oh [ __ ]
it just make you think you know because
like with me with voting it's all about
me personally like certain people are
going to vote on things that's
important to them whether you know it's
not i don't like trump or biden i don't
like either
copy that so for me what affects me is
their tax laws right so i'm a vote based
off tax laws
well the biggest tax cut for me would be
trump right so but with biden's plan
it's crazy
but when you hear in trump's uh funding
towards the military well i'm gonna vote
for that too because i
believe in a strong military so when you
hear tim kennedy talk about it
and he goes you know you can vote for
you want because as far as military go
they're going to be a lot of them are
pro-trump because when obama was in
uh office he was very reserved wasn't
given the military funding and isis kind
of flourished
started popping up all over it was trump
came in
gave us the funding and what he says
released the hounds
was like yeah there's gonna be some
casualties but do what you want to beat
isis
you know how long it took our special
forces to beat isis
three months three months instead of the
four years with obama
with the proper funding and capabilities
our military's the baddest on earth it
took him three months
shout out to esee's that makes me proud
to be amazing that's isis
what have you done
also if you a cop that's watching this
if you think black people is dangerous
go to brendan shopping we were shooting
guns you see me shoot gun you like you
know what i understand
he wasn't that tight i was uh i was i
was tired oh you weren't that ghost
i think i probably out of out of all the
black guys over there
all the black guys over there copy that
i probably was the best no no
no no come on i made the shot
i made the shot that we all but but like
overall if we're gonna
oh no colin was the best oh well we're
talking about
who has a shady history with stevie blue
eyes that's all
hey stevie yeah
i don't know i don't know if we're
speaking to parole officers i don't know
oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're right i don't know
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah bro
i got a lot of details
you did not touch a gun uh this weekend
for these white guys bruh they was in
like
they were killing me they was like
because we do shout outs all the time
i did a 50 cent bar and yeah didn't even
think of it
it was like man you you you biting malik
i was like i didn't i didn't mean it
you know i mean so many white boys
called me cornbread what did you do uh
because we was in a conversation talking
about denzel
and i was like uh uh what is um i watch
i watch gangster flicks and roof for the
bad guy and turn it off before the end
before the bad guy die
that's a 50 cent bar but i was like oh
wait wait a minute and then it went
blank and i was like that was hard
was like man you come up with that you
cornball i was like okay go so why are
you
why are you staying away and white guys
white guys i'm talking about white guys
are like that well
i don't know our demographic i thought
we was like i don't know i don't know i
didn't grab it but i was like man you
better shout them out so shout out to 50
50.
lisa d everybody who i didn't shout out
that last episode oh god they serious
about that
they was like we're show love hip-hop
are serious about they serious about him
about him 50's getting [ __ ] because he
posted biden's tax plan and was like
i saw that i vote for this i'll be 20
cents
openly too your empty is so ruthless but
he's saying what
everybody thinks they're just not going
to say because no one yeah
that's why i [ __ ] with 50. you gotta
have some cajones
brothers thank you what do you think
he's gonna say
he he's a do you think he cares about
people's feelings he's a beast dude when
you think about all the [ __ ] he does oh
he does a lot of [ __ ] bro vitamin water
sold it for
and two million dollars g-unit g-units
he's doing a bunch of stuff man a bunch
of stuff he's got smart shoes
yeah oh power yeah i mean
someone was trying to say yeah he was
broken on like 50 cents oh because he
followed
but when they bankrupt they try saying
the same thing with trump they're like
oh he's broke
let's see his uh actual reports because
look it's a strategic move
or like it's a business chapter 11 yeah
it's a business
chapter 11 chapter 7 either way they do
it out of business what's he got branson
cognac or something like that is that
his
yeah he has a bunch of [ __ ] his alcohol
yeah he's got alcohol he launched some
new thing too he's
killing it dude fifty laws of power he
got a book you know i mean it's a great
book yeah
so he's just he's just like he ain't not
reading 50's book wait that was
like he didn't write i like 50 no yes
ghost writer but yeah i'm all set
let you say i'm all set legit
he always like hashtags yeah
300 i don't know it's not much it's what
300 bucks for champagne for
champagne champagne are people buying
that what does champagne taste like
i'm not a big champagne guy it's just
like oh
oh really yeah he sent it to mark
because why because mark uh
did uh 50 central 50 cent 50 cent had a
sketch show
shout out to bbt you never saw it i
didn't think so but uh yeah
to be fair i don't think a lot of people
saw 50
central no well he was hiring a lot of
black comedians yeah i'm sure
50 cent doing comedy again like his book
allah
i love how that one white guy is in the
oh
hey we did it buddy we did it and that's
power by the way
no that's a problem yeah yeah lala's on
power right right right right right
right right right right right central
that looks awful look at his life
probably did good
yeah even though he got killed yeah see
he's a comic no he's an actor yeah yeah
but like yeah
he does a fellow thespian jasmine that's
a fine girl jack you talking about
baddie comedy you go to her page
hey he's done a lot i mean yeah even
though what 50 central what probably
failed i don't know is that still a
thing no it doesn't matter look at 50
cents
actually there is there's mark again
yeah he all up in the band look at this
he was at the bet awards and all that
damn yeah
with those long locks mm-hmm by the way
swinging b get that [ __ ] though
hey if you found it flowing man what's
up dog come on now
but you don't skip but but yeah that's
but the whole um
there's like yo shout outs and all that
like white boys are serious about then i
got into like an argument
you still stay you got an argument in
dms or on you know
is funny they called him that was like
jordan woods with like uh before surgery
looked like chappelle i thought that was
hilarious
that was goddamn hilarious i was like
well [ __ ] keep it coming
why didn't you look like pre-surgery
first you'll do it oh that's cool yo
that's hilarious
that's hilarious how i get it that's a
lamb they was killing me too i'm like yo
it's a [ __ ] i
oh no go to the black and white ones
yeah
yo i got it i got a black and white
junior high picture that's right
i wish i remember that dude's name so i
could shout him out but he had me crying
she's a baddie now she bad yeah
i can't wait she started only fans man
she gonna start her only fans
yeah man we talked about this yeah
that's her with her doctor look at the
doctor's face
he's like oh he's like a famous doctor
huh don't he got a tv show like he got
uh i think that's a different one you're
thinking of the doctor from botched
oh yeah they all kind of look like they
they all have the botox where they don't
move and it's like this
so like eyebrows okay so is this not is
okay is this
not a healthy thing to do to your face
well botox is fine
wait what's up what's that thing with
the eyebrows what do you all mean by
that with the eyebrows well brian
looks exactly i know that's just i don't
know what happened my auntie
that's what i'm saying like so these
surgeries are not bad for them
they're not invasive other than a needle
going through
it's not like you're they're cutting
anything out or putting on botox just
the needle goes straight into the yeah
they use that for the face for medical
stuff for headaches and stuff like that
too
oh really it just relaxes your muscles
if you have sweat plants too like
if you have real sweaty hands or armpits
or feet they'll botox their feet and
hands
and it stops the sweating i don't want
to make this a race thing
no does black people get that do we do
black people
okay i didn't know i didn't find a black
person with botox yeah vivian fox
okay let's see by the way i'm just 50
and she's a baddie yeah but she's
definitely had some [ __ ] done okay
i was like vivian okay come on you can
play that game come on chin come with me
now
she ain't got she got no goddamn blip
black no crack don't cry
look at him bro brittany you ain't got
it today
bow out
look at her face it does look like she's
making them that's a lot of looking
is that her daughter to the right no
that's zendaya oh she dated 50.
all roads lead back to 50. look at this
all leading back
out so you break for saying sure one
unexpected side effect this year it
feels like
fashion is over i'm talking about fast
fashion i don't know about you but i
don't even know what the trends are
nowadays i kind of do but listen most
people don't
know so how are we supposed to know what
are we supposed to shop for
do what i did don't buy for now buy
forever
for timeless pieces that will last a
lifetime
check out faraday all right that's all
i'm gonna say check out faraday makes
high quality comfortable clothing
for life they're sustainably minded
designing products with thoughtful focus
and fabrics
every piece is made to last forever and
it's guaranteed
all right the company is run by faraday
family and they are very hands-on
uh they do it all themselves all right
and
let's see the legend collection is so my
favorite the
legend collection it's legendary this is
the softest coziest shirt i've ever worn
i'm rocking it all the time it's a good
thing that the quality stands up to
everyday wear because i want to wear it
every dang day
buying forever is the smartest way to
shop other designer stuff
falling apart not this we're talking
about faraday man and now is the
smartest time to do it right now you can
get 25 percent off your next faraday
purchase
when you go to faritybrand.com fighter
that's faridy
f-a-h-e-r-t-y brand
dot-com slash fighter for 25 off 25
percent off
veritybrand.com fighter all right fellas
let's take a little break because my boy
all the way from new york is on the line
i'm talking about mark
norman he has a special on youtube right
now it's probably the best you'll see on
youtube
it's called out to lunch you can watch
it right now for free
one of the funniest men in the business
my
brother from another mother all the way
from new york mark norman
mr mark norman what's happening brother
hey
good to see you fatty it's been years
so much has happened the world's shut
down your
studio is like it's like my
ex-girlfriend she's gone black
yeah yeah man things have changed you
know things are a little different now
with curry you got a couple of kamalas
[Laughter]
it were like kamala but we kicked biden
out you know we got really old man
so
how's new york man is it as bad as it
seems on tv
or it it's not that bad the bronx is
rough but
uh it's just everybody left and there's
a lot of hobos
and it's getting a little dicey but it's
still fun
this comedy shows were on a roof or in a
parking lot you name it
i saw you doing comedy shows and uh
parks
yeah yeah it's come to that
you're just doing it straight up what
gave you the idea doing parks just
because you were forced that's the only
place you can do it
yeah everybody's covered crazy so stand
up new york said hell we'll do it in a
park we'll get a microphone
and we'll hit our mailing list and now
we're in central park
i got birds [ __ ] on me i got sun
cancer i got a
mosquito biting me and there's kids
playing and i'm talking about queefs
you know into a microphone under a tree
hey i heard you say
i heard you say uh you can actually hear
crickets like you know that you'd be
able to
know it's crickets out there because no
seriously i can hear crickets
yeah complete it's bad man it's i call
it the methadone of comedy it's not the
real heroine but you just it gets you by
yeah we need the real thing but you can
go on the road some right like i've been
you know and i got i paid for it i was
the canary in the coal mine and i got
covered but
i've been on tour during this whole
pandemic yeah
same i've been doing like funny bones
and heliums
you know they're half full so i'm
finally selling out but
uh yeah it's
i mean going into it because it's magic
it's like oh i didn't realize what we
had you know you're in a green room
the crowd is hot it's great yeah you're
putting a lot of content out though i
think it's forcing
comics to kind of get more creative as
far as digital goes like i see putting
out a bunch more clips stuff like that
so
i think in one aspect that's good more
guys are getting creative and putting
content out so
people don't forget about them i guess
that's true
we're trying to stay relevant you gotta
get creative and i hope this uh
fluffs off a few you know hobbyists
you know if you weren't in it for the
love of it yeah hit the road
yeah if you're not doing because you
love it you know especially now you're
getting half pay on the road and stuff
like that those
those other hacks aren't out there you
know
exactly exactly so hopefully because
comedy got real hot you know
youtube and netflix and all this [ __ ] so
everybody jumped on the bandwagon but
once they see it's tough uh i think
it'll be
i think it'll kick a lot of people out
hit the bricks i say
but you were smart because i a few
comics did and few of them failed but
you're smart because you released your
special during the pandemic right
yes good call good call yeah great time
to release content is during a pandemic
i mean people are stuck at home we're
quarantined
so i got some some pretty solid views on
that [ __ ]
that thing's over a mill yeah oh we're
3.6
there's sloppy jalopy and counting i
feel like
uh i was maybe uh 10 views of that
i watched it and i also posted it
thank you sir you've watched it more
times than my parents that's for sure
did you did you have it ready to go was
this planned
i shot it in january nobody would buy it
so i said [ __ ] it i'm shooting it myself
and uh thank god i did so then we just
edited it color corrected that thing and
put it out in may
how the [ __ ] did nobody buy it are you
pitching it yourself or you have one of
those sleazy agents
kind of push it to netflix or comedy
central
i had a sleazy agent i had me i had
everything trying to push it but
you know i don't check any boxes i'm a
skinny white guy
it's a there's a lot of us you know i
know sarah cooper
so uh you know nobody wanted it so what
what can you do
they don't even watch it they don't
watch it they just go ah we don't like
the look
he looks like a douche [ __ ] him and i'm
kind of glad i put it on my own now it's
a blessing in disguise because
i get all the money i can chop it up i
own it yes
yeah i think you know schultz is doing
the same thing too although now he might
you know be going with a major
distributor but i think
it's strange because you're such a beast
at the art of stand up
that they wouldn't look at it and give
you a platform
is it fresh is it frustrating for you
because you know every comic
is gonna say you know you talk about
guys who are
great at the craft right now no one says
mark norman's not up there
you know top ten right now so uh you
talk to anyone you know so
is it frustrating for you you know
you're [ __ ] you're good at comedy man it
has to be frustrating oh
hey thanks i can't take a compliment but
uh
yeah it's frustrating it was more
hurtful like hey you work so hard at
something
and you you [ __ ] slave over this
thing
no offense and it just
you know it just sucks
because
by the way it's so great having a black
people in the room because in new york
everybody's
so tense with everything so it's nice
black people laugh and then these these
stiff honkies out there go oh
what are you doing and you're like shut
up
but yeah yeah it's uh it's a pain in the
ass it's a bummer you know what can you
do it
because funny now is 13th on the list of
what people want in
in the industry of comedy you know and
and the the business side they don't
give a funny funny's out i mean look at
all the specials
these days they're pretty rough so um
you know i don't know i don't fit them
all but [ __ ] it i'm on youtube and
youtube seems to be
youtube's now feel like what podcasts
were eight years ago
everybody's like there's no money in
that [ __ ] that and now look at podcasts
yeah and i think more comics are gonna
realize that they have the power and
you actually get more views unless
you're like a seinfeld or chris rock or
you know chappelle if you're if you're
not those guys
you're going to get more views put on
youtube and owning all of it and posting
clips and promoting it there because
everybody can get youtube
exactly exactly yeah and i think the
good sticks out a little bit
and the people talking i mean look at
reddit red is just a big
sewing circle full of dweebs and in
cells and they get together and they
start clamoring and then boom
you got a hit agree man no i think it
was smart
brother uh how's your how's everything
have you seen
have you seen your reddit it's [ __ ]
terrifying no these people are nuts
i stay off of it man i stay off and i
just read it
and now i stay off and hopefully do you
read them you read all that [ __ ]
i have it boy i had to i had to turn my
lights off close the blinds and get in a
fetal position for three weeks so it's
so painful
yeah yeah i don't know man i yeah i
don't look for validation from uh
guys on reddit fortunately smart move
how's how's things going with the with
the lady friend out there during
quarantine
pretty good pretty good you know a lot
of movies
we're cooking it's it's like a lifetime
movie over here you know where we
she's got a little icing on her nose and
i i rape her you know it's fun
because for a lot of couples this this
pandemic this quarantine has
caused him to break up you know it's
been rough to hang out
no this was good where we we hang we
we like a little down time it's not so
bad so we're having a good go at it
and uh also with comedy i was on the
road i was out every night so
i know we didn't even know each other
until the pandemic yeah you're forced to
get to know each other
do you miss the hang like i'm sure
you're at the cellar and stuff missing
the boys
or do you still see people out there ah
i miss everybody but we're getting there
a little like the cellar's still open
they have dinner so like i had lunch
with sam morillo the other day i see joe
list with the podcast
uh you know podcasting is really keeping
me with seeing all my friends ironically
thank god for those but we have free
time so we sit in the park we had a
cigar with ari two days ago i mean
we're getting out there you gotta see
the pals and and stay
sane is uh are a lot of your buddies in
new york especially the comics are they
are they leaving new york cause new
york's a [ __ ] show like is in la so
all my friends have left so that's why
you just see me now
[Music]
oh yeah yeah what are you what are you
gonna do i mean
my friends are still here uh no one's
stuck in our lease
no one's living in new york nobody's
leaving in new york no the main comics
or anything
not really not really like all the big
ones are still here you know you're a
tell your colin quinn
seinfeld they're all staying they all
have more money than me but
i don't know new york you kind of get
that apartment it's so hard to find and
you you get you put your roots in this
place like joey diaz is back now
tim hilton comes back every now and then
schultz was born here
yeah you know like we're staying i don't
know i'm proud of l.a
l.a seems worse with the shutdown uh
i don't know l.a a lot of a lot of
frauds you know like as soon as things
got rough everybody dipped out it's like
what
i thought what happened oh everyone's
gonna leave what the [ __ ]
i know i know well you got you got chris
sure and bill burr i guess they're
staying but
yeah even like theo and segora here is
leaving and
uh you know diaz yeah it's tough
rogan rogan that's tough man yeah it's a
bit of a bummer but i think
once things opened up those guys would
be in and out of la
so they might have left but they'll be
in and out hopefully you know
it's just about yeah it's just a bummer
because like even at the store they were
trying to
put on shows outside and they had like a
bar and they had outside
shows and the city shut them down that's
where we're at
ah that's what i hear i mean the taxes
the shutdown it feels like it's getting
nutty the hobos
i mean yeah you guys are what's the
upside after a while if you can't go to
the beach you can't go to the nice
restaurants
the taxes are you know [ __ ] on your
face you're kind of screwed
yeah but taxes are jizz in your face in
new york as well my man
that's true but we got the comedy clubs
are opening up the stand is opening now
the seller
so we're paying for it sure but at least
we got some amenities coming in
yeah you right i'll give you that you're
right you any predictions on the
election next week
i will say this i don't know anything
about politics i've never voted in my
life
uh i know that's uh you can't say that
[ __ ] now but i'm clueless i don't watch
the news really
but i say this i travel the country and
all i see is trump
posters and flags that's what i call
this
what keep going that's what i keep
saying like if i think if you're in la
in new york you're like oh biden's
winning for sure
yeah as soon as i get out i'm like oh
[ __ ] i think trump's gonna win
i know exactly so it's a toss-up because
like all these people are voting early
it's a record amount of votes have come
in for biden already so
but that's what we said about hillary so
what the hell do i know but
i just hope trump loses so we can stop
talking about trump i got trump fatigue
everybody's got their 20 minutes on
trump and it's hacky now and
every news story but here's the question
there shabby
every comedy show is trump-based colbert
seth myers snl uh samantha b
it's all trump trump trump jokes so then
what happens
if he loses i don't know they're screwed
that's the only material they have all
their riders are just
anti-trump it's the only thing they have
what happens to cnn
what the hell are they giving yeah yeah
he's a ratings
booster so who knows who knows
i just i hate that we're so political
now we're so divided it's it's all very
strange
agree brother well hopefully uh after
election i do think things are going to
open up in new york you're already
headed in the right direction
because i was going to do shows at the
uh forgot what theater i was at out
there
do you remember what theater gramercy i
was at the gram scene you were gonna
we're gonna do shows together
so yeah hopefully next year i'm gonna
rebook
new york and we'll be able to do shows
together man that'd be nice it'd be nice
to see it
i mean just to have a show planned in
the books feels good now because the
calendar is so empty everybody keeps
canceling which you know i get it but
boy i gotta tell you this pandemic has
made me grateful for comedy i i
kind of took it for granted like ah
going to jfk again here we go
funny bone merchandise you know closer
waitress you know but uh now i love it i
get to a green room like oh give me
those wings
give me a cocktail let's go bust it out
and do some jokes
and the hotel room and all that but yeah
i didn't know what i had
i agree man well when i get to new york
it's gonna be thick crust and mark
norman that's the plan brother here here
let's do it baby
all right brother well we we miss you
man and uh
appreciate you coming on man even though
it's zoom it's better than nothing man
yes yes it's good to see it's it's it's
not the real thing but it's
it's phone sex you know i still
i still orgasmed wait am i done already
that was
what am i quibby it's over it's quick
geez that was four minutes but all right
i'll see you buddy
here come here do you have any shows
coming up
are you on the road again i am i am i
mean i'm in
atlantic city this weekend at ac comedy
club next weekend i'm at
cleveland hilarity's great club great i
got a ton of shows in the books
you know buffalo new orleans you name it
so uh we on buffalo
helium yeah helium that's a great club
oh yeah so yeah come on out folks
say hello i'll hug give a hug dude
give are you wearing are you wearing a
master in the meet and greets
i am but uh i've already had it so i
kind of feel invincible
me too i love it yeah so that's nice
how was that is it rough for you
yeah it was about three days of hell but
it just came and went
yep yep yep yeah mine wasn't too bad but
for
everyone's different i guess i think so
i think if you're fat
or gay you're [ __ ] but
no i'm kidding i'm kidding but yeah hey
i'll see you on the road baby
kanye 20 20.
all right brother we got your special up
now so you guys can go watch it now it's
uh out to lunch it's on youtube
that's mark norman we love you man we
miss you and i'll see you soon in person
same here baby praise allah
he's so stupid he's so [ __ ] feeling
no he's dumb dog
he's my favorite he's great wait let me
do mine first oh
should we i mean okay you got a new you
have a car in the back sure the current
event right oh he's got he has a news
report he's got a news report yeah this
is the news let's see the news reporter
welcome back it's justin let's just say
it back welcome back today
okay well i'm just doing my intro
welcome back this is t-fat kz
with your man malik b i'm gonna tell you
something that you don't even know about
that's going on in the news
check this out b look so check this out
dog so look
the ceo of twitter right now what are
you making
jack dorsey right the ceo of facebook
mark zuckerberg
and the ceo of google sandra pattay
right yeah
sunder patel that's a joke all right
look bruh they gotta they gotta go to a
con
in front of the congress they don't
really gotta go because it's you know a
pandemic yeah right so they took
face time with it they facetime and
virtual right so they doing it because
trump called them out over that bite and
[ __ ] right both parties
they uh suppress news suppressed news
fighting sun hunter go ahead okay i'm
getting to it look so two
like they going they fighting the
section 230. now what you probably
thinking is what's 2 30
right it's a 1996 act that let you know
it's a yeah yeah that's before
facebook and twitter it looks like we
got you off a wheelchair and sat
down like this the wheelchair's gonna
fit in here so we just picked him up
he's off the thinking bro why are your
legs you know you like this
you like you're you asking what dorsey
is doing huh
you're like this what the [ __ ]
all right
baby i love you so look this is what it
is all right cool cool so it's section
two
damn it
1996 bro listen many law experts right
consider foundational to protect or
protecting facial expression
for your first expression yes all right
on the internet look so check this out
both parties having a
like disagreement about it now what
you're probably thinking is who the
parties the red guys with the ties on
they write
right so look they far right so right
that you got to turn your steering wheel
so look they arguing like yo y'all
censoring all that [ __ ] online
right and ebonics i'm trying to get you
and okay i was like bro and also
we ain't trying to accentuate stuff and
we're gonna talk it's free speech
free press let's do it first we have
first amendment bill a shout out to the
bill of rights now look
check this out the dudes and the blue
ties for
left left yeah far left because that way
turn right
look they saying like dog we we got a
problem with y'all like saying hateful
stuff online
and we got a pro y'all just like
involving you know other countries doing
the presidential campaign
right there's like man we we tired of it
this [ __ ] need to change right
so peep game both of them got their own
people in the congress they got like a
dude in a red suit in congress and they
got like a dude in a blue suit
in congress right remember left and
right that's important right so this
dude named ted cruz
right he was like bro i'm gonna
interview jack dorsey remember he
tweeted tweeting twitter you know
falling there with him
on there supposedly smartest man come
out of harvard a long time
he was attorney now i thought ted cruz
was that dude who beat jimmy kimmel and
one-on-one in 2018
not him don't look him up right a
different one cool for
my street dudes so look bruh so he was
like look i'm actually straight up
did you or did you not censor stuff
online on twitter you know what this
dude jack dorsey
i've never seen a dude before but he he
kind of looked like that dude you know
hugh laurie but either way he was like
dog no i didn't
he was like he was so appalled he was
like now i'ma ask you again
i said did you or did you not because
you like you know when you lied to
someone's face you like i know you
just yeah okay cool okay so he goes
i'm actually again did you or did you
not
censor stuff online he was like no i
think you can get other outlets to like
yo
straight lie to him in the supreme court
this morning ted cruz was like who the
hell do you think you are
you [ __ ] okay thank you but you
know what they're suppressing this is
the problem is
if if they suppress news like that we're
gonna turn to china because
what twitter and facebook is doing is
they're censoring news
that could hurt biden win the election
because the news that they're
suppressing
is news again it's not it's not fake
news it's it's real [ __ ]
real emails that they're not saying are
fake they're agreeing that they're real
but it's emails of his son hunter biden
who worked for joe biden
that was doing business with ukraine and
china they have emails
they have tax to back it up that they
were getting funding and money from
china and ukraine
to uh get deals for the biden family
and so they suppress that information
they didn't want to go go
like crazy this is where what you found
out did you just say what i said but
smarter
i just said the information okay cool so
your point is it's
it's twitter jack dorsey jack dorsey
live
live yep i think because he did suppress
he sensed her don't like remember i own
supreme court come on you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] twitter twitter's gonna be
[ __ ] twitter no and then facebook
they're gonna be [ __ ] well you
suppress information especially like
that
that's illegal but well no because
they're private businesses
but wait hold on haha you thought it was
over i know haha
this is where mark zuckerberg was like
yo hold on i'm cool with like
opening uh like more avenues on like for
facebook like he's like bro you know
what we did it
hey i did it oh he admitted he mean
like the facebook's uh board of
censorship
are chinese people shout out to them oh
wait wait wait what i didn't i didn't
read that in my mind i thought mark
zuckerberg didn't own facebook no
well he well well he does ceo oh [ __ ] oh
sorry okay okay well anyways so then
you'll check my girl out i looked at her
up annie coleman uh what's her name
uh uh any uh who just got who just got
elected to uh ac
oh amy amy acb she's just like she a
full-time senator now bro cause you know
trump she got voted into she got voted
in
congratulations to her but a lot of
people don't agree with her because
she's pro
uh abortion right she's super religious
she's super religious and all that she
fought
she's a beast though smart lady smart
lady copy that
right so boom check this out for life
she pro-life that's what i i mean
pro-abortion i don't want it and and the
the right is
uh pro-choice usually because you gotta
turn it all the way okay cool
left is pro choice that's right yeah
sorry left right you see how you
confused me bringing i studied it gets
dicey
god damn it i'm done that was your news
reporter
like we know this hunter biden joe biden
stuff is corrupt and you look at the
dollar stuff now it's i just
yeah that's that's what you want i don't
like either these [ __ ] that's
what you want as your president
yeah we know it's gonna be compromised
our relationship with china and ukraine
now and he's gonna be president
china and russia's our biggest
liabilities and that's gonna be our
president we know he's taking funding
from them and
funding his family and their businesses
like you just it's a conflict of
interest
and the fact that and the fact that they
suppressed all that information because
i tried to google it
when you told me that i'll send you the
links new york new york post which is
100 years old is the one that got the
information
and they blocked their their twitter
feed so they couldn't get a hello
twitter world
sort of work they blocked their twitter
feed which is you talking about 100 year
old magazine
that doesn't just post [ __ ] news
talking about legit news
but um free press it's not yeah it's
just yeah it's
weird for the first amendment where
these mega social media sites decide
what informations get out
just to help biden like it's insane you
just
can't have that it's too much it's too
way too much
but then they let all that [ __ ] run
against trump when he was trying to get
into presidency with russia all that
collusion stuff
what's fine what turns out is all the
stuff they're accusing trump of
biden was doing we have we know for a
fact for a fact and it's evidence and
then they're suppressing that
exactly so that's why he's like and then
that's what trump does
china and north korea does to their
people they only give them information
that they want out
and it's not a democracy over there
communism but look at the information
y'all dropping on me
i don't know what the [ __ ] but it's
important you know because dude
because you're on twitter well on
twitter well it's important because
what you got to realize is like this is
how communism starts is when the media
starts dictating what news
to sway your opinion like if you don't
have all the facts
it's a big deal man that's why how they
or how spotify they're trying to they
can't how they want to censor joe rose
hold up dude if he wants to have these
people on you want to
censor him base you just want the news
that you agree without you can't have
that
that's not that's why that's why america
is the greatest place on earth because
it's freedom of speech
it's not communist over here it's not no
you know what communism is like
everybody over there is one
it's like you can have like you can be a
doctor dictators it's dictators and i we
don't live by a dictatorship we don't
like it you know that's what china is
for i like it
copy that good job
first one's from chappelle actually yeah
oh [ __ ] you got a current event
yeah i have a current event well i
didn't read the [ __ ] article but okay
okay you know well we ain't got it
cursed
but that was aggressive yeah look at my
man oh
speaking of botox
he looked good
no more whoa look at that transformation
whoa look at that transformation i read
the caption gee this yo
it's your current event don't ever give
up come on you're gonna have to make
that bigger
you said article this is a [ __ ]
instagram post dude no it's i mean it
was the current thing everyone was
talking about
uh don't ever give up on yourself life
begins right now
my dedication is different i would never
put out an album and not be in the best
shape of my life
i respect myself too much and i respect
you all too much i'm only here to
inspire
ellie to the rest that's his name this
is his album
ele to the wrath of god dropping
pre-orders
available thank you coach victor munoz
thank you we got it oh okay
i know right my point is yeah
look how fat that [ __ ] was
that's pretty and then look what he got
to
you don't think we can make that happen
i think that dude had a triple chin
um i don't know if we can make it happen
we can
yeah straight dieting did you have your
boy come up with any plans yeah he has
well first of all what what is what are
we trying to do
okay we're trying to lose weight or what
is the challenge what's the challenge
who can lose the most weight by the end
of january by the end of january so
that's very first yeah because i'm
sitting here i don't know what to say to
him because
i'm just like what is our challenge so
november
so we'll start in november we'll start
november 1st so november through
february 1st so you can lose the most
november november 1st two so what was
that night so basically 90 days
90 day challenge 90 day fiance challenge
yeah i love how you doing any
[Applause]
how much you weigh right now 260. okay
i'll be honest with no we need the
pictures of the weight scale on
instagram we don't i trust
them no we can i'll we can do it you
come to the crib but i gotta give you
gear anyways
okay yes i'll come to the crib we'll
weigh in and we'll weigh in we'll start
from that day
start from that day all right this is
just gonna have chick-fil-a today
sure starts november 1st or wherever you
want i just went on vacation so i'll
probably 261 i bet
yeah okay i'm probably like 250
something yeah oh
also i had a uh at 5 11. a quote as you
know
we both got to lose weight i know we
both got to lose weight but we can make
it happen
and on the road we have to hold each
other responding i think we could do it
yeah i think if we're together we'll be
fine yeah jay's trying to lose weight
too
so yeah yeah exactly yeah jay what eats
eggs yeah yeah yeah stevie he [ __ ] he
gets a
he gets food uh the groceries delivered
yeah he's gonna be cooking himself
you don't really eat bad no i don't the
only person that ain't bad is justin
let's just be honest
no i eat bad no doesn't eat a lot of
[ __ ] dude if you give me a reasonably
bad i'll be back
oh same i'll be back same all right i
had a question since november 1st i'm
going nuts
i'm making my good ass chicken tongue
tonight oh foreign yeah we have to do it
november 1st because let me let me write
out
halloween's coming yeah saturday kids
pizza party yeah yeah yeah no valley's
excuse me november 1st
okay that's the challenge that is
november first monday
thursday no it's sunday oh yeah because
halloween is a holiday saturday so
sunday
so sunday easy does it easy peasy
japanese yep okay
i also had a quote for my kearney are
you sean your current event well no i
didn't you did good don't [ __ ] it up
well no i just
i just had this quote and i wonder
who's the quote from first of all it's
from andrew hamilton uh 1735
okay okay he goes andrew yeah andrew
hamilton and i'm not anthony you're
probably thinking of anthony hamilton i
thought
alexander hamilton but okay
um he goes tyrus injured
oppressed the people under their
administration provoking them to
cry out and complain and then make that
very outcry the foundation for new
oppressions
and persecutions then he goes you like
where
where did you get that from home i know
you're confused i got it from
yeah i got it from the trial of
john peter zinger i don't know who that
is and he was a kilano
i don't know what that is colonel he's a
colonel okay connor
well this isn't a quote it's a paragraph
yeah right gee what the hell you want me
to do i like it better when your legs
are like this though yeah right yeah i'm
not doing that
doing that i'm messing my legs did i
mess it up did i mess it up like
i failed yeah
it was solid okay
losing weight inspired us lose some
weight what else we got we got this
so here's the update to the guy who did
the scooter the scooter trick who didn't
make it
this is an updated video
so this is the one that we watched
dead oh he's okay he's okay and this is
a couple days ago what happened he
pulled it off
hold on was there a second one on there
yeah yeah yeah
you hit it watch just keep it playing
because he's awesome
he's wearing a different shirt that's
the first one now brendan watch
never give up the boys it's so thick
never give brushes on a scooter never
give up
he pulled it off pulled it off dude he's
a champion and i wrote that dude
what did you say i i told him uh i think
i said congrats
that's religion that's what i congrats
with like a bunch of exclamation points
that's it i'm happy for that guy yeah
what do you want to say mother congrats
he did it congratulations good morning
spot did he respond back
no i'm waiting on it text patchy or
whatever the hell his name is
actually i think it's x x dot underscore
apache
and he's also i think he's from the uk
was three wide sounds like pechay
so a um group of
kazakh how do you kazuko
so kazuka american association actually
denounced borat 2 for coming out
and they penned a letter to amazon
telling them basically that they want an
apology and for
amazon to pool the movie because they
don't like
that borat is going around making up
these stereotypes
about kazakhstan and giving them a bad
image
they say why is our small nation fair
game for public ridicule
yeah it's uh no one sasha baron cohen
this is what he wants right he wants
he's like polarizing he wants
all these headlines like the i watched
it last night did you see that
was it any good i was cracking up he's
funny man it's just funny it's just
there's i mean he means no harm like
i don't know because like rudy giuliani
like the thing they did with him what
happened with that
oh was it legit was it legit that was
legit and it was kind of crazy
he saw that right i saw it too oh he saw
it i i saw the uh
the clip the ruby on rudy it was it
because he like they're like oh he was
he was sexual that girl touched her back
he patted on the back
and then when he gets on the bed because
he's [ __ ]
80 he's taking the mic he took his mic
off and the shirt came out on so
he's it looks like he's back back he's
talking to sheridan like this
and they're like oh he's jacking up or
doing something so that was a little
iffy but i mean as far as him
asking the girl for her number and then
going to the room with her was there
anything weird with that or no
i i i i it was a bad headline it was it
was it's a stretch i
i think it's a huge it was it was uh it
was pretty two different opinions
yeah my girlfriend my girlfriend were
watching last night and when that part
came we were like
you both y'all just kissed up yeah that
was the part that made me
bring it did you send this up are you
using no i know i i saw what the
the far right or far left did and i'm
like oh [ __ ] rudy's in trouble man
then i watch them like this is what
everybody's yeah it was it was i mean i
guess it was
push it it was pushed to make it happen
of course
yeah you know what i mean so like i took
it as just comedy i'm gonna check it out
you know what i mean i took it that's
what sasha baron cohen wants
but then yeah he asked for censorship on
[ __ ] alex
jones and other people so dude
you want to play both like you you want
everyone to be all good with what you're
doing
but then because you don't like what
this person says you want to censor them
yeah it is kind of like i just i can't
be your friend i can't [ __ ] with you
anymore i just took it strictly for
comedy i didn't take it beyond
what this [ __ ] was just making me you
know you know trump and him got into it
over twitter you all know that right
sushman cohen him no no the guy giuliani
yeah giuliani
no well trump and julia again they're
that's his that's trump's lawyer who's
the guy on board red too
yeah that big guy well yeah yeah but i
mean yeah that that part was a little
it'll make you intense if you haven't
seen it remember it's edited
it's designed to make him look bad even
in
that i don't see an issue with it i mean
with giuliani like there's nothing there
again it's taking focus on
biden and [ __ ] hunter biden in
collusion with russia and ukraine
that's real [ __ ] dude we know for a fact
that is real man
yep section and again i don't like i
don't like either [ __ ] i mean
yeah but when you look at that's like i
can't vote for that and you want to
raise my taxes yep
one more question about that scene
though so i because i only read about it
yeah it says that i was like it's
supposed to be no like
she's supposed to be known as a 15 year
old girl did he have any idea that she
was no no no no okay okay that's not it
and the actress isn't no she's older
she's like 24 25 she's like 20 something
yeah but still i mean like
okay i watched this strictly for the
fact of it just being comedy i didn't
want to take it any
further than like this is some you know
political [ __ ] or like
this is making fun of a country i don't
look at giuliani different i don't look
at
the country that he was portraying
different i don't look at any different
i just
you know he's thinking about july
everybody wants to [ __ ] on him because
he's
trump's lawyer now and there's this
crazy stuff but let me put you on game
on uh
rudy giuliani rudy giuliani is the
greatest mayor of new york's ever had
when he became there new york was a [ __ ]
show dude new york was dangerous times
square was dangerous
it was run by mafia he went in there and
incorporated the rico
act and he made new york what it is he
made new york safe
he made broadway safe he got rid of the
mafia
yeah broadway used to do shows and
people would run out before
because he was so dangerous around there
not anymore he cleaned it up
and like with mafia guys they could
never catch the boss because
they always have like you know their
their lower level guys
doing all their [ __ ] they could catch
them but can never get to the boss
so the rico act made it whoever gave him
orders from the top
would get charged with it too so they'd
all get charged so he cleaned up the
city man
rudy giuliani is a [ __ ] beast he
could have ran for president when
remember how big of a deal is when
september 11th happened and the way he
dealt with it his rating was through the
roof you all must have forgot everybody
wants to [ __ ] on rudy giuliani he's a
beast
everybody talking about everybody i
don't know really oh
dude people make fun of him now because
he's trump's lawyer but he's a he was a
[ __ ] beast
i don't know bro yeah uh sasha baron
cohen also came out and said that the
whole world
came out uh not out like that but like
he made a statement
uh he made a statement saying that he
chose the country
uh kazakhstan because most americans
don't know much about it
so it's easier to get people to say
stupid [ __ ] that
then shows their bias towards the middle
east and stuff like that
and kazakhstan has gotten so popular
because of borat
that they started to make like a whole
section of their
tourism campaign with the phrase very
nice
very nice yeah very nice it's nice yeah
i mean yeah you think about it like when
the when he
when borat one came out no one freaking
was sitting here writing a [ __ ] load of
articles because that's what i'm saying
because he didn't get that political he
didn't go after it wasn't political in
that first one not really
it wasn't going after like now his
agenda's to [ __ ] on trump and our
society and stuff yeah this one is much
more political than the first i'm gonna
check it out
i can't remember the first one because
it was so long ago
i remember he got ron uh ron paul i
voted for ron paul back then he got him
in a room and did some
like i guess just some weird [ __ ] some
stuff yeah ron paul who was that
he was a president candidate uh i don't
know how many years ago but
yeah yeah i mean twelve years ago
a while ago i think one came out 14
years ago
yeah whatever what else you got all
right
so this was submitted by joey ramona on
instagram
they want us to react to jean-claude van
damme's instagram page with this video
as
the start let's see it's just him kind
of vibing out
[Music]
high [ __ ] you want to see the smile
i'm very happy i was not thought
i was thinking
um i was focused
what because
i love a guy talking about final
solution
[Music]
tomorrow will be announced but be happy
because the solution is there can you
believe that
not from me it's from me and
a group of people who are fantastic that
you're going
and also something else which is very
powerful right now
yeah his eyes and he's high yeah no
dude look at his eyes i know what i have
never seen the documentary on show time
you know like three do a bunch of coke
nine it will work i promise you
it will work if not i'm not worth
to exist yeah that's a nice little
straight
through cooler uppercut this is like a
two-minute video
oh hell yeah like oh [ __ ] he danced like
my uncle
hell yeah don't get lost in the sauce
he grooving come on man i have no
[ __ ] clue what he's talking about i
don't know what he's saying that's how
you talk
i think he was on instagram live and
then they give you an option where you
can save that whole instagram live video
afterwards
so you don't see the uh comments and
stuff i think that's who he's addressing
oh
that's somebody's uncle hey uh who is
this his last poster did he update
uh i think he has two more posts uh how
old is he
[ __ ] deliver ever oh he has a couple oh
damn
oh he's 60. oh look i love that's a dope
b day picture oh good uppercut oh
wait you know that leg can get up there
do that hold on play that again um
between one bro you know that leg and
get up high look at that
damn he landed it hard he saw the next
day
between 1000 to 1500
gallons a day which is about
six to seven thousand five hundred
liters someone checked i think yeah so
if
you want to see more of him he has a
youtube channel now
oh hell yeah he said about what he said
what i don't know diesel needed collab
oh yeah vanisho's trying to get on tick
tock now
say less he doesn't show his subscribers
either oh you can show it yeah you can
choose
but this that's a good amount of views
200 000 i thought that was harvey from
tmz
wow interesting oh yeah his face doesn't
look like it yeah
so what is he just he's really high
i don't know i assume so watch crazy
yeah i'd say
he's high yeah damn when you get high
you should be talking about
anything oh man i did that he has a
music video
wait wait wait you talked about it a
while ago
yeah yeah we did you said you wanted to
recreate it at one of your
toys yeah [ __ ] uh so this was sentient
for you brendan from
tim barnett on instagram your boy zach
baggins from
ghost adventures is selling the los
feliz
uh charles manson murder house for 2.2
million
oh he owns that house yup the guy from
ghost hunters
yeah zach ballin man two points
[ __ ] wow so that that was the
that would have been uh the murders
after sheriff after so they killed
sharon tate and then later went to this
house
and it was a husband and wife they
weren't like anyone famous
they decided they just want to keep the
chaos going it is a beautiful house
though that place is dope haunted but
nobody wanted that [ __ ] but
did he did he take a tour of this on
ghost hunters i'm sure
he owns it you know what zack baggins
did almost cynthia's current event he
went to the
uh joe exotic tiger ranch and did uh
ghost adventures there
i guess haunted as [ __ ] really from like
people
or like he doesn't have that land
anymore
joe exotic right i think the gov the
government might have took over
they sold it to the one homeboy took
over and then he got
[ __ ] yeah who's going to buy that
manson house though i don't know
somebody who's really into stuff like
this i'm really into it i don't want to
own the house though
yeah because because it didn't want to
buy it and like rent it out as like a
haunted airbnb
i'm sure they've redone it yeah right
like it there's no way it's still the
same house from the set
early i don't even know if it's
necessarily a home that he lives in
it almost seems like the way the article
is written it's like a novelty house
i don't want that bad juju nowhere no
that's probably why you're getting rid
of it
straight up exotic animal oh yeah that's
joe exotic's thing
i was talking to this girl from ohio
this weekend and she was uh telling me
that
like when she she lives in ohio remember
like in what 1996
all his animals got loose that day did
they show that oh they showed that in a
documentary yeah
and but i don't think it was joe's it
was someone else there's another joke
she says
oh and what you say i just want to bring
awareness to
it oh there's no end to that story okay
the
club i performed at in uh tampa side
splitters they said carol baskin would
go there all the time to watch
shows that's cool yeah i don't know why
people give a [ __ ] about that lady
i know she came out as bisexual again i
don't give a [ __ ] was that when your
current events no that was his
i don't care why are you looking at me
crazy though no that's not news is it
is it how's she doing on dancing with
this channel i put it off first
like
i don't get her you know she killed her
husband we're all celebrating this [ __ ]
i know right
like can you imagine they both j on
dancing with the stars they put o.j on
the dance floor no i said
imagine if they did like it's no
different i think it'd be a lot more
exciting
what if he can dance what if he wins his
footwork come on now
he's got footwork his highlights oh he's
a beast
for 2000 yards man bro so much that he
got he got away with murder mm-hmm
if you think about how good talented
that is damn say less
what else you got can you guys look up
for a second
welcome brother all right now look do
you know who this guy is
yeah yeah it's uh uh ryan yeah how crazy
is look now
that's ryan seacrest he dyed his beer
what happened i have no idea he just
looks very very different to me
american idol american idol his face is
a little yeah why he liked this i just
have a friend whose
assistant and she said um someone left a
cupcake in the room and he freaked out
because he doesn't eat carbs uh-huh he
freaked the [ __ ] out because they had a
cupcake on the table
oh this is the dude he's like everybody
get out and then he just stared at why
does he look so different i don't know
this is just a dude
he redid his hair to me this looks so
different almost like he's
and then like kind of transitioning in a
way
that's the that's the kind of look that
i know transitioning
what do you mean like a bruce jenner
type of
he's not doing anything like that i'm
just saying that's the kind of look that
i see
it almost looks like fake facial hair in
a way oh god
i think it's died i think his finisher
has died looks ridiculous yo
20 second sprints 10 second breaks on
repeat for 25 minutes my shirt is
drenched in sweat and tears
this lady i think shrimp real housewives
orange county goes
keep this content coming get the [ __ ]
out
but no then kelly ripa lights him up
who's
i worked with kelly she's [ __ ]
brilliant wants to she put that's nice
sweetie p.s
lola wants her shirt back that's her
daughter oh damn yo these comments is
like you read them dog it's so funny i
don't know what lola is but i just
imagine that's her daughter
kelly rep is a beast she is super smart
bro yes
she used to be on all my children did
you ever watch that
yep and she hosted uh well she still
does the kelly and
ripa show right who's she with straight
hand no she heard strand hated each
other you know that
are you serious i heard those rumors
hated each other really
i don't know did she get did she get
along with uh oh boy the old one before
him
yeah our lasers are super close and then
now it's right her and ryan ryan's
secrets yeah
mine does so much [ __ ] ryan's about so
you know ryan found the kardashians
started his eyes showed the kardashians
yeah
so yeah is it a sex tape no he just
thought the family's interest decided to
start
a reality show wow he's a beast he's
worth
so much money but he continues to work
crazy crazy hours and days he is yeah he
does radio every morning if you listen
to the radio while you're driving in
he's the is he the white nick cannon
yes way bigger than that kidding but he
cannon is
a different version of him they can't be
the black version of ryan seacrest
right secrets beast damn i didn't know
that he was the host from american idol
i knew that you know what you know
what's funny about american idol is him
and another host
yeah and the other dude was like yeah
this game i remember it was a duo
yeah oh they were a duo yeah and ryan
what 430 million dollars
he probably worth more too probably yeah
he's killing it he was on a dating show
at first remember he did a dating show
he was a host yeah i forgot what it was
though what knicks so
that was a good show that was a great
show that's only wow i didn't know he
was rolling like that yeah he's
what's up ryan secretary it's that
kardashian money though that's that that
got to be a kardashians they bring
anytime you would a kardashian look at
jordan woods nobody now she making [ __ ]
but they weren't before
like he's the one who produced the shows
his idea like
he's a beast he's already had money
before he started
you're the production house of it you
know you're making pain and the idea is
too
yeah the ideas yep all right how are you
in his 40s i think 40s mid-40s
45 dude the day after my birthday
that's why he's successful i get it he's
a capricorn
all right um they say we like moves this
is from crazy one designs
okay this is how cool is this
10 seconds segment how cool is this
wait did he just do it yeah oh but made
it much cooler
[Music]
do it again often does he go to the
water park i know it's his land there
first of all
someone said this to me so that was
pretty dope
wow and uh wait hold on wait hold on
wait this guy oh my boy design he might
know
jesus pr person or something and then
fabulous go cool runnings
that was a great movie by leon you
should have won him oscar cat you were
mentioning this yesterday i think
how adele looks oh yeah is super
different now
we all know that she's been losing
weight because the internet lost their
show when they first saw
photos i think almost like a year later
yeah because i think
she came out or like her trainer came
out and told everyone what diet she was
on
and it was very restrictive so people
gave her a lot of [ __ ] for it
for being having discipline yeah
something chappelle can't do
yeah yeah people were just mad like how
dare you talk about her
diet because it's so restrictive and
it's triggering for people
like i don't know it's like stuff for
people
yeah listen for lazy people these people
need to [ __ ] take care of themselves
yeah shut your [ __ ] yeah
eating could bring an adele into your
life if you have a problem
and you're triggered it's your problem
it's
rapper in the uk right now too oh black
dude right no no
wait whoa i forgot what his name was but
yeah a black rapper over in the uk he's
pretty big
she was off really married to like the
schlumpy dude and then divorced him got
all sexy and got
the black was it was the british rep
skepta that's uh asap
but she down with the swirl he got that
old face i know right
now y'all
i don't know what that man girl he got
that forever tatted on his neck
she doesn't look great wait how old is
he i don't know skepta
nigerian rapper oh nigerian
38 yeah she's what bro you're out your
goddamn mind you think
i only look a year younger than him
she's 32. well that was probably a bad
picture that was probably
they probably got bad pictures no it's
his face it's whatever wait
i mean he looks different right there
yeah those are old pictures that looks
like something
but that's more recent this is history
let's go to his gram and we'll see his
current ones
that looks like a current photo let's
see let no no it don't i'm gonna give my
man some credit
because brendan what you 39 right uh 38
37 37
37. let's see what you look like
currently that's if this is old or not
but oh
man yeah see that's a bad look at that
oh
man i was a bad jesus yeah
but that was a old face though these
pictures all look old still
nah this is what it's not that's a
filter
that ain't no filter
yeah yeah that's that doesn't like the
bad ass riding oh
[ __ ] damn you ever wrote it in the room
with asap rocky yeah that's his homie
that he was on his album skepto was on
a7 oh
got it okay so i just thought this was
interesting um
this is in russia and this girl was
stealing stuff and putting in her
underwear
so she saw a bunch of different things
and was able to shove it in underwater
and the other thing that's weird about
this is she's kind of bodied up if you
look at her oh yeah oh i don't know
what type of neuro was she wearing i
have no idea but you'll see
and they're not together by the way so
she that's like a drink right
oh she put it in between your tits is
that why they look so big yeah
yeah big but then
look she shoves it that's like a milk
carton does her body show up after she
don't have any money huh
that's another thing i don't i can't
imagine that that's about she doesn't
look like someone that would be
poor if that sounds
she's stealing like that i love my
channel was like yo she bodied up
oh [ __ ] she showed you jordan woods
she built my like my legs are you over
here talking about yo she bought it
hope you guys are ready for this bobby
that bread
when did i i learned how to pick up this
before his version of bodied up is very
different from everywhere he's like oh
he was like the curves on taylor swift
the baby got back
how about the tits on that screen
oh my god yo that's so funny kid
what the [ __ ] he's bodied up
he did what was that
he did come in hot when he was like yo
listen i'm just ready for some
some ass yeah
okay shout out to 21 savage oh good ass
and titties
i don't know what this is but uh yeah
acl here's what's worried about this
super uh football dive here so
whatever but uh baker mayfield's uh
better when um
he's out okay but because he's so
focused on getting the ball to
[ __ ] odell beckham he misses a lot of
other reads and stuff like that and his
interceptions go through the roof
so he's actually a better player when
odell's out i'm a hotel fan he's one of
my favorite players
i'm just saying if you're a cleveland
fan you shouldn't be too worried
that's one game brenden he was up there
hey they beat the bengals
listen he only did that he only did that
hell of a game one time
overall season for season it's he's
better when odell is out of the game
because that's
too focused on him okay now you got
landry you got a bunch of other tools
too
okay let's put like this and if he sucks
this the rest of the season
oh yeah okay so he just ruined that man
career for
no reason okay all right shout out to
obj yeah
lsu represents one of my faves yeah
i don't know anything about him so
that's good man he just he listen the
guy threw an interception
and he loves to win he could have easily
gave up on the play but he was running
trying to get
the guy he wasn't running like dk
metcalf a monday night football no you
said yeah
you pull that up he chased them down
over russell wilson interception and
matching that
was like six five 240 bro little dude
what was the guy uh shout out to the
cardinals man oh it was
it wasn't patrick peterson wasn't it no
hello okay
okay uh this young guy cornerback i'm
talking about
he should've been a touchdown he was
crazy yeah in
so they're in the end zone right he ran
115 yards and tracked this dude down
dude booked it booked it dawg that
should have been we got to do like
highlights of the of the week that's the
highlight of the week
yeah damn it that's pretty much it
well we are in phoenix next week
thursday friday saturday shows almost
sold out
phoenix arizona stand up live with this
crew and a special guest
phoenix arizona november 5th through the
7th
then nashville also almost sold out
we're going to add extra shows so don't
sweat it oh [ __ ] that is
zany's in nashville uh november 19th
21st also special guest there as well
including these boys
and then boise idaho uh let's sell that
[ __ ] out so we had another show that is
december 5th
in boise idaho it's actually right
outside boise but you get the idea boys
you're close enough
boise iho is december 5th all right
phoenix next week nashville
november 19th 21st boise december 5th
tfatkay.com for tickets
thick boy gear we just posted uh restock
the jerseys we'll have new stuff
dropping next month that's thickboy.com
for everything thick
chapelle lacy yes that's me yeah uh
merch
i know i'm gonna get it to you i swear
to god i got you uh
and then uh tour dates i'll be
headlining my hometown
uh thanksgiving weekend november 27th
through the 29th
uh those tickets are on sale go to
chapellacy.com
um come hang out with me and bring a
turkey uh
actually you know i don't really [ __ ]
with turkey like that bring uh
yeah the cranberry sauce what the what
do you mix it with yeah
come on baby look at us being thick bro
that's gonna be tough on our diet that's
gonna be really
about this we could get like a little
cheat meal then you can do cheat meal oh
we can do cheat meals talk your boy
about cheat me
yeah yeah come on now come on skip wait
hold on hold on
you type in malik b shop.com what
do you guys think me and jay me and jay
look at look what we did shout out
oh no i'm my bad malik b store doctor
all right
here we go okay okay all right then we
gave you the wrong weapon i
didn't know all right we didn't know
which one we was gonna go with
what what malek b store are you saying
malik b are you spelling is mlik
yeah okay yeah dot com or dot something
else um it's dot com this dot com it's
the real one
yeah still not working oh oh oh i'm
sorry what dot
big cartel dot com uh it's not the
fixture
why don't you have uh dot com there you
go yeah
okay there it is
it well hold on now this is what don't
don't go on the product that's all we
got
all right we're still working on double
checking this is like it's like it
sounds like a b
store.bigcartel.com yeah
that's cool yeah that is dope who's the
model
some dude i think they use like stock
photos that's right
all right please there you go man thank
you yeah all right see you in nashville
next week
uh something with you phoenix oh my bad
phoenix next week i don't know where i'm
at all right